je veux pas dire que ce qui vous est
arrivé n'était pas traumatisant atterrir
ont atterri au milieu de nulle part
complètement coupée des vies qu'on avait
laissé des rien
ce qui nous amène à la question qui nous
intéresse tous souvent qu'est ce qu'elle
avait lui aussi grandiose et si
merveilleux les [ __ ] de vie
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que où que j'aille on
attend de moi que je réponde précisément
à toutes les attentes
[Musique]
à l'arrêt
on est coincés ici on est au 21ème
siècle les filles ils vont nous trouver
ma vie et tout là-bas à des millions de
kilomètres
ici d'accord c'est vrai il ya eu des
traumatismes et pour une adolescente
vivant dans notre amérique si c'était ça
le véritable enfer
on peut dire que la mort rôde au dessus
copains
[Musique]
pourtant les seules choses qui sont
intéressés c'est lourd
c'est parce qu'il nous effraie tous on a
tous peur depuis le traité
dans le triangle des bermudes oui
l'impression que quelque chose clochait
dit
m
[Musique]
quel genre de personnes voient une île
rempli de vies perdues et dans votre
pâte renforce votre fille a commencé la
remontée d'un sombre précipiter
parfois je me sens coupable d'avoir dû
mentir à notre fille vous avez fait ça
pour la sauver
ton